Good morning everyone.
We are on the cusp of Valentine's Day.
So I thought it was appropriate for us all to tell Rome how much we love Roma
Roma,
how much we love her.
Uh,
and so I've done that here.
I've loved Rome for as long as you know,
for,
for a long time,
certainly from the age that you are now.
Uh,
and I know that there are many of you in this class who feel the same way and I
hope that those of you who entered this class without having those strong
feelings for Rome have come to love the city and its civilization as much as I
do.
So this is the kind of Valentine lecture for Rome.
And I think that the particular topic that it is,
is appropriate in the sense that we are going to be looking at a number of quite
eclectic monuments today.
Very different monuments,
one from the next,
and they're full of surprises.
And Rome is always full of surprises.
Roma city of course,
that you see layers upon layer of civilization that when peels back to get us
back to antiquity.
But along the way experiences some amazing things.
So I think that this particular lecture,
which we'll talk about,
the varied nature of Roman architecture,
especially architecture commissioned by individual patrons to preserve their
memory for posterity again,
is particularly appropriate.
I've called today's lecture accessing afterlife tombs of Roman aristocrats,
Freedman and slaves.
We spoke on Tuesday about a public architecture commissioned by the Emperor
Augustus public architecture that we noted was made primarily out of marble out
of Luna or Carrara marble that was quarried on the northwest coast of Italy
itself.
And the objective of it being a to try to conjure up a,
the relationship between the new golden age of Augustus and the Golden Age fifth
century BC of Pericles and Athens.
Uh,
just as Julius Caesar had tried to create a kind of Alexandria on the Tiber,
we see Augustus trying to recreate a,
an Athens on the Tiber.
And Augustus was of course very much in his objectives,
was very much in keeping with other objectives that we've been studying for some
time.
This Hellenization of Roman architecture,
uh,
that we have addressed on a number of occasions.
We spoke last time about the forum of Augustus in Rome,
uh,
featuring the temple of Marzel tour.
That temple that Augustus vowed he would bill he would build if he could be
victorious over the assassination of Julius Caesar.
That is Cassius and Brutus.
He was so,
uh,
at the battle of Philippi.
And he built this forum and he built temple again as it's centerpiece.
And you'll recall again that it was made for the most part out of Carrara
marble.
Uh,
we see the columns of Corolla here,
a wall,
uh,
the 17 Carrara marble steps and so on.
We also talked about the Arra pockets.
Our goose die,
the altar of Augustan peace put up to the diplomatic of the diplomatic,
uh,
agreements are treaties that Augustus made a with those in Spain and gall,
a monument that was put up,
uh,
near his earlier mausoleum,
a monument that was also made out of Carrara marble.
And in fact,
uh,
solid Carrara marble and this monument to had a precedence in the Greek period.
It looked back to a number of sources,
but one of those is we noted on Tuesday was the altar of the 12 gods or the
altar of pity,
uh,
a fifth century BC,
a monument that was located in the marketplace of ancient Greece.
So again,
both of these buildings looking back to Greek prototypes in their general format
and also of course in the material out of which they were made,
namely marble.
When we talked about the Arra Pacas,
uh,
we talked about the fact that it eventually ended up being part of a kind of
architectural complex that while this architectural complex may have not been
planned from the start,
it grew up over time into something where all of the buildings related to one
another in interesting ways,
both in terms of their content and also in terms of their architectural design.
The complex,
uh,
included the mausoleum of Augustus,
the tomb of the emperor Augustus,
which was the first monument built on this site.
And eventually the Arra pockets,
which you'll recall,
was actually not located originally where it is now.
It was located in an area a bit here to the upper right.
Originally on the via Flaminia that Augustus took when he returned to Rome from
Spain and gall.
Uh,
but that it was moved or the remains of it were moved over to this location next
to the Tiber by Mussolini because as we noted last time,
in the meantime,
a palace had been built on top of the original location of the our pockets and
that area was no longer available for use,
but again,
the mausoleum of Augustus,
the first building of this complex you see in this aerial view from Google
Earth,
uh,
that the,
mausoleum ended up becoming the centerpiece of the Piatsa Boosto imperatore that
Piatsa that Mussolini's architects designed to commemorate Augustus and also to
commemorate a Mussolini because that inscription I showed you last time is
inserted into the building over here.
If we look at this aerial view of the mausoleum of Augustus,
uh,
which you'll see from your monument list was begun in 28 BC.
And in fact,
that should ring some bells for you.
And we should say something about,
it's about its genesis in 28 BC because you'll recall that important date of 31
31 the battle of Actium when Augustus was a victorious over Antony and Cleopatra
and became sole emperor or began his march to becoming sole emperor of the Roman
world.
It's interesting to see him building this massive mausoleum only three years
after the battle of APP APP Actium.
That's really quite striking.
Why did he do that?
Uh,
well,
the reason that he seems to have done that is despite the fact that he lived
until 76 years old,
which was very old and ancient Roman times as I mentioned last time,
uh,
despite the fact that he lived to that ripe old age,
he was not in terribly good health even as a young man.
And he was very concerned about his own longevity.
How long was he going to live?
He knew he had accomplished a lot already by this victory over Antony and
Cleopatra and by some of his other military victories.
But he wasn't actually sure how long he was going to last.
And so he begins to build this gigantic,
a tomb,
a eventually to hold his own remains,
and he completes that tomb in five years.
It's built between 28 BC and 23 BC.
And you'll recall the date of the Yarra Park.
This is considerably later,
13 to nine BC.
So the are apoc.
This was only added to this complex later.
And at that point,
the whole thing was orchestrated with the addition of the obelisk.
And we talked about the obelisk cast a shadow on,
uh,
on the Arra,
Pakistan Augustus,
his birthday,
and so on and so forth.
With regard to the tomb itself,
we're going to see something quite striking today,
and that is that the tomb is architecturally very different from the Arra pocket
sell,
goose die,
and indeed from the forum of Augustus.
And it's a good example of the eccentricity as will characterize today of Roman
to marketecture in general.
Keep in mind that Roman to market texture is the most personal of any form of
Roman architecture,
which makes it particularly interesting to study because the only practical
requirement for a tomb was that it be able to hold,
uh,
the remains of the deceased.
That's all it needed to do.
Whereas other buildings not to do all kinds of other things have running water
through them and so on and so forth.
But that was not the case here so that the,
the patron and the architects could come together to create buildings that were
unique to that individual.
And again,
uh,
we're,
we're eccentric to a certain degree and that is indeed what we will see.
And that is the case also in the mausoleum of Augustus.
As we look down on the mausoleum of Augustus in this aerial view,
we see,
uh,
the general plan of it.
We see that there was a central burial chamber,
that there was a hollow drum.
And around that hollow drum in all of this is made of concrete construction
around that hollowed drum,
a series of concentric rings,
a series of concentric rings as you can see them here,
again,
made out of concrete.
And then the outer wall,
which you can also see in this view,
the outer wall was faced with travertine,
which is also interesting,
not Luna marble travertine blocks.
And let me show you a,
another,
uh,
somewhat closer view also from Google Earth,
to show you the structure.
So again,
the central burial chamber,
the Hollow Drum,
the concentric rings around that,
the travertine wall around that.
Uh,
but of course you're looking essentially at the core.
This is not what the original,
uh,
entire monument looked like.
And what it was was in fact there was a,
an earthen tumultuous or an earthen mound that was placed on top of these
concentric rings.
Uh,
and then at the very apex of that earthen mound was a gleaming bronze statue of
the emperor Augustus himself.
I think I can make this clearer,
but from sh by showing you a plan of the mausoleum of Augustus.
And we see all the features I've already described,
the central burial chamber,
the hollow drum get all made out of concrete construction and the concentric
rings around that.
And then the cross section at the top is particularly helpful I think,
because you can see the way in which the concrete has been built up by means
obviously of annular volts of the annular volts and ultimately support the
gleaming bronze statue of Augustus at the apex.
And you can also see in this cross section,
the earth and mound,
the way in which the earthen mound is piled up on top of that substructure,
that concrete substructure to create the,
um,
the,
the dome like shape of the mausoleum,
uh,
on its own.
Now,
scholars who believe,
and we all believe in fact that the,
uh,
that again Augustus was a Phil Helaine,
that he had a particular pension for things Greek.
So you look at something like this and you ask yourselves,
well,
what's Greek about this?
I mean,
why didn't he,
when he came,
when he came to make the decision about,
uh,
his last resting place,
why did he not want to be,
be,
be laid to rest in the manner of the Greeks?
Why doesn't this,
why wasn't this to made in the form,
for example,
of a Greek temple or something like that?
Why did he choose this particular form?
So scholars have debated for quite some time whether there are any tombs like
this in Greece,
weather,
a weather or an Asia minor,
whether Alexandra,
what kind of tune was Alexander the great buried in,
for example?
Well,
we don't know exactly for sure.
Uh,
but that's one possibility that it might have something to do with Alexander's
tomb.
Others because,
uh,
I had a niece came from burning Troy,
others have suggested perhaps,
and that's an Asia minor.
Uh,
perhaps,
uh,
the,
the way the Trojans were buried might have something to do with this selection.
But I think the model is much closer at hand.
I think the model myself,
I believe that the model comes from Italy and it's a very interesting choice on
the part of Augustus because I think what it tells us is that Augustus may have
wanted to build public buildings in Rome,
uh,
that conjured up ancient Athens.
But when it came to deciding about he will,
how he wanted to be buried,
he wanted to be buried in the manner of his Italian ancestors.
Let me show you what I think is a really important comparison.
We're looking on the lefthand side of the screen once again at the mausoleum of
Augustus.
As it looks today,
here you see the central entrance way.
You see what remains of the concentric concrete rings.
You see some of the,
uh,
travertine facing for the outer ring of the structure and do see of course that
the upper most part,
namely the earth and mount is no longer there.
But if I compare the mausoleum of Augustus to what you see here on the right
hand side of the screen,
which is any trust skin tomb and a trust can tomb from the so called,
and I put this on the monument list for you,
the Bondi Tacia cemetery,
uh,
which is in this at a site called chair Vettery chair Vettery a very important
to trust skin site.
Uh,
and this tomb we believe dates to the sixth,
sixth century BC chair.
Vettery is an extraordinary place to visit now because there is one tomb after
another of this type.
You go into the site and you feel like you've,
you know,
on another planet or some such as you wander among these extremely well
preserved tombs at your veteran.
Sure.
Battery by the way,
is right off the highway between Rome and Florence.
So it's very easy site to get,
get to in very well worthwhile.
There's nothing quite like it anywhere in Italy,
anywhere indeed in the world.
And you see these series and I've just chosen one here to show you.
You see these series of tunes and I think if you look at it,
you'll see the similarity of this to the mausoleum of Augustus.
These round a trust in tombs have central burial chambers.
They have stone,
a stone facing around the outermost part of the structure.
And you can see that piled on top of that is an earthen mound.
Uh,
and if you expand the size,
the cheer Vettery tomb is much baller.
Actually,
the Individual Chair Vettery tombs are smaller than the mausoleum of Augustus.
The Muslim of Augustus is 290 feet in diameter.
It's very large building.
But if you expand the size of one of these,
what we call to Mulas,
t u m U L U S to Mulas tombs at your Vettery,
if you expand the size,
if you plant this with trees,
because we know that the mausoleum of Augustus was planted with trees on the
earth and mound,
there's been quite a bit of controversy about what kind of trees.
For a long time people said Cypress trees.
Now people seem to favor juniper trees,
but whatever trees of some sort,
a decorating that earth and mountain.
So if you acts,
if you enlarge this,
if you put some juniper is on top of it,
and if you stick a gleaming bronze statue of Augustus at the apex,
you will have essentially the mausoleum of Augustus.
So I'd like to suggest to you today,
uh,
that the mausoleum of Augustus indicates to us that when it came to his tomb,
Augustus wanted to be buried like as Italian ancestors,
like the trust skins.
Uh,
and that is why he chose this particular type of tomb in Rome,
the mausoleum of Augustus.
Like so many other monuments that we'd been looking at this semester survives in
large part because it was reused over the centuries in a wide variety of ways.
Uh,
you can see in this engraving that it was used at one point as a garden,
a very nicely manicured garden.
As you can see inside,
uh,
the remains inside those concentric circles.
Very Nice Garden.
Uh,
it was also used as a fortress at one point by the well known Colona family of
Italy.
It was used,
believe it or not,
as a bull ring,
a little touch of Spain in the midst of Rome as a bullring.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it was used most recently as a music hall.
It was a music hall before it was turned back into the mausoleum of Augustus.
So again,
this very,
very similar saga to this building and its post antique history as to so many
others that we've talked about.
Another important point to make about the mausoleum of Augustus is that although
Augustus intended it as his own lab last resting place,
he didn't intend for him to be the only person who was laid to rest there.
He wanted this to serve as a family tomb for him.
His wife,
his well,
it turned out his daughter didn't end up there,
but that may have been the intention originally that she would,
she was discredited because of all the adulterous affairs.
She had an Augustus eventually banished her in to BC from Rome,
raised her house to the ground,
and did not allow her to be buried in the mausoleum of Augustus.
But for his wife,
for his,
uh,
um,
nephew and son in law,
Marcellus and others,
he wanted to create this family tomb where he,
his family and presumably since his objective was to create a dynasty presumably
where his successors of the dynasty that he founded would also be laid to rest.
And there are inscription plaques that have come to light from the mausoleum of
Augustus.
And I can show you a couple of them here that do indicate that as exactly was
exactly the case.
We see this plaque over here,
which actually has the name Marcellus inscribed there.
This is the Marcellus of the theater of Marcellus,
the nephew and son in law of,
uh,
of uh,
Augustus who was laid to rest in this Mozal Liam.
Uh,
his sister Sora Octavia,
also laid to rest.
That is Augustus.
His sister Octavia also laid to rest here and it continued to be used as the
burial place again after Augustus to us after Augustus is death and through the
so called Julio,
Claudia,
and emperors who will look at next week,
Tiberius and Caligula and Claudius.
Uh,
and we see in fact an inscription plaque over here that honors Agra peanut,
the elder Agra peanut,
the elder,
the mother of Colliculi,
the third emperor of Rome.
And it was Caligula who laid his mother to rest in this tomb.
So very much a family tomb,
uh,
created by the emperor Augustus.
And I should also mention with regard to burial practice at this time that
everybody was imperial perial individuals.
And those lower on the social pyramid as well,
uh,
were all cremated at this particular time.
So you have to imagine that there were earns for each of these inside the tomb
somewhere as well.
Now,
it may not surprise you to hear that,
that once the emperor chose,
uh,
the form of his tomb,
that he set in motion a fashion,
uh,
that just about every aristocrat wanted to follow.
So all of a sudden,
after the construction of the Mazda Liam of Augustus,
again,
between 28 and 23,
there is this efflorescence of round tombs in Rome and elsewhere in Italy.
And I want to show you just one example of that.
This is the so called tomb of Cecilia Metalla.
It dates to 20 BC,
so it began to be put up not too long after Augustus's mausoleum was built.
It is located on the famous via Apia in Rome,
the op Ian Way,
uh,
the option way,
which you see this is a Google earth image once again,
where you can see I stretch of the Appian way or the,
uh,
be Apia that is modern asphalt,
although there are remains,
and I'll show you later.
And example of this,
there are remains of the polygonal masonry wall floor pavement that would have
been,
they're initially looking very much like the pavement that we saw in palm pay,
for example.
And you can see the tomb of Cecilia Patella right over here,
like the mausoleum of Augustus.
It was reused in ancient times and there was a fortress and a palace that was
added to it.
And you can see also there in a red reddish earth color,
uh,
the remains of that fortress and palace.
That was,
that abutted the mausoleum of the tomb of Cecilia Patella.
And while this is on the screen,
you can also see that while the tomb was essentially a cylindrical drum
resembling the cylindrical drum of the mausoleum of Augustus,
it was placed.
It was given some height by being placed on a podium.
The kind of podium that we saw at the sanctuaries of the podium that we saw at
the Ville of the mysteries to raise it up.
It's not as big as those,
but it's sizable.
And it raises this around tomb up a little bit so that it can be more readily
seen as people make their way along the via Apia.
The Mausoleum of Augustus does not have,
uh,
a similar podium.
So that's a unique,
a different feature that is added to this particular structure.
You can also see there's an inscription on the front and we'll talk about that
in a moment.
And then are crenelations at the top.
There's some dispute about when those crenelations were added,
whether they belong to the original tumor,
not,
I think it's highly unlikely that they belong to the original tomb and they may
have been added at the time that this was made into a fortress,
a,
as I've already mentioned,
this is a view of the tomb of Cecilia Patella as it looks today,
this tomb of this woman,
uh,
and 20 BC.
And you can see that it's actually quite well preserved and we can get a very
good sense of its original appearance.
You can see the concrete podium down here without its original facing.
It was surely faced.
You can see the great cylindrical drum of the tomb of Cecilia [inaudible] and
you can see the facing and once again,
the facing for this tomb,
just as in the mausoleum of Augustus is not Luna or Carrara marble.
It is travertine,
but very,
very nicely cut travertine blocks as you can see here.
Very well done.
Uh,
she was undoubtedly a well to do patron who was able to hire the best
architects,
the best artisans,
and they have done an outstanding job of cutting that travertine.
Uh,
you can see also the,
that there is a freeze a bit that encircles the monument at the upper most part,
uh,
right here.
And that frees,
depicts garlands and skulls of Bulls Bu Cranio the same sort of thing that we
saw on the inner precinct wall of the RF pacas although this predates the Arra
pacas.
So we can't say that was the influence of the [inaudible] pockets.
This is again 20,
whereas the,
our pockets wasn't begun until 13,
and it shows us that this motif was very much in the air,
uh,
during the Augustan period.
This motif of garlands hanging from [inaudible],
which of course makes reference to sacrifice.
And it could be a sacrifice in honor of a funerary,
uh,
a s a event as well as anything else.
And we again see that very well here.
One very interesting fact is that freeze is not made out of trapper team,
but out of pentelic marble,
C pentelic marble is marble from Mt.
Penn Telecon in Greece.
So it tells us that marble was imported from Greece or marble that was important
from Greece,
was purchased and used for the freeze of this particular structure.
And we'll see that it was used also for the inscription plaque.
So it tells us something,
it tells us that there was,
that some patrons made the decision to spend a little more for the material for
what they considered the most important part of the monument.
So in this case,
the most important part of the monument was the freeze,
uh,
and also the inscription plaque that preserved this woman's name for posterity.
So,
uh,
they paid a little bit more,
in order to get that more expensive material for that critical,
those critical details of the monument.
Here's the inscription.
We're very fortunate that it's still preserved today.
We see it still inserted into the monument.
Again,
it's done in pentelic marble.
And I think you can see even in this view,
uh,
the difference between pentelic marble and uh,
and,
um,
travertine,
travertine has more texture to it.
Uh,
then the,
uh,
the planer a marble,
as you can see,
a,
and her name is given here,
Cecelia Metalla,
Cecilia Metalla and Cecilia metalla down here.
And it tells us that she was the daughter f Phelia Flia,
the daughter of Quintess Queue Kritikos credit,
cus c,
r e t,
I c u s who may have come from Crete.
It's possible,
uh,
and uh,
it also makes reference to the fact that she was married to someone by the name
of Crassus.
This may be crass as the elder,
we're not absolutely sure,
but what it does indicate to us is this is an aristocratic woman.
This is an aristocratic woman whose family has a great deal of money,
who are honoring her with this tomb in the mode of the day,
which of course was,
uh,
the,
the tomb type that was chosen by Augustus himself.
You may have noticed up here in this same detail,
not only the freeze that we've already described with the garlands and Bu
Cranium,
but that there is a relief here that represents a Roman trophy.
What is a Roman trophy?
A Roman trophy.
Uh,
what the Romans did at the end of battle if they were victorious,
is they went over to the nearest tree trunk on the battlefield and they took
arms and armor from there,
defeated enemy and they tacked that on arms and armor up on that tree trunk to
create a military trophy commemorating their victory,
right on the battlefield.
And that's exactly what you see here.
A tree trunk with a breastplate,
a helmet and shields and so on,
all tacked up,
uh,
to that trophy.
So we have to ask ourselves,
what does that trophy doing on this particular monument?
It's highly unlikely that it refers to it.
There are,
there are some instances,
um,
well we do do here about women trying to raise troops,
raise money for troops and so on and so forth.
But we don't,
and,
and even thinking that they might go into battle,
but for the most part,
Roman women did not participate in battle.
So it is highly unlikely that this refers to a military,
uh,
and and counter that she had,
more likely at either refers to a military encounter of her father or her
husband,
or it may be a more generic reference to victory.
We've talked about the fact that in the minds of the Romans,
the victory,
oh,
victory in battle,
victory and hunt and hunt,
uh,
often were conflated with victory over death.
So it could be a more generic reference,
but I would guess it may have something to do more specifically with the
conquest of her husband or her father.
The,
uh,
structure today,
is um,
uh,
is right just right there out on the via Apia easy to see.
Uh,
there is a small museum that isn't all that often open,
but sometimes it is a,
that is in the remains of the fortress and the palace next door.
You can see that the outside of the monument,
they've inserted a lot of fines just from the,
didn't doesn't mean they came from the tomb of Cecilia Martella,
but from this area on the Vop,
there were tons of Roman tombs out here,
uh,
and all of this paraphernalia that you see,
statuary and fragments of freezes and cornices and so on,
all come in part possibly from this monument,
but more likely from the other tombs in the area.
Those have been inserted into the wall and kind of interesting way.
And then here's the tea.
The museum itself,
the museum doesn't have the stuff that's in there is pretty much the same sort
of thing that you see here.
But going into the museum is interesting because you can see into the central
chamber of the Tomb of Cecilia Patella and see the concrete construction and so
on.
I mentioned already that Roman tombs could be very eccentric indeed.
And I want to show you one of the two most eccentric tombs in my opinion,
uh,
from ancient Rome that one can see in the city of Rome today.
Uh,
and the first of these is the so called tomb of Cassius because we believe,
in fact,
we're absolutely sure that it honors a man by the name of Gaius Gai,
U s Castias Csti u s guy is [inaudible].
It was put up in 15 BC that is in the age of the emperor Augustus in this Google
Earth Ariel view.
We see what that structure looks like today.
It is the,
it is a Roman tomb in the form of an Egyptian pyramid.
Uh,
it's the only Roman tomb in the form of an Egyptian pyramid that we can see in
Rome today.
But we know there were others in antique antiquity.
We have,
we have,
um,
reports that tell us that certain others that existed at a certain time were
torn down at one point.
That was one,
for example,
not far from where the,
the Vatican that was torn down at one point because it got in the way of the
street.
Uh,
but so this is not unique in the sense of the only one,
although it is the only one still surviving today.
We have no idea how many of these there were.
There was certainly some weather,
there were a lot.
We can't,
we can't be absolutely certain,
but here it is a Roman tomb in the form of a pyramid.
Now,
when it was first put up,
it was put up outside the Serbian walls of the city.
Uh,
because all as we've talked about the fact that by Roman law,
the necropolis or city of the dead needed to be located outside the walls of the
city.
But as the city grew and as there was a need for a new wall,
and this happened,
uh,
in the third century,
a d and we'll talk about it way at the end of the semester,
uh,
the Romans ended up building a new wall.
This is the famous and really in walls.
And the circuit happened to be planned for this particular Depasse,
this particular point where the tomb of Cassius was.
And fortunately,
uh,
they recognize the aesthetic and historical value of this tomb and decided not
to tear it down,
but rather to incorporate it into the wall.
So what you see in this aerial view are two of the walls of the two.
Uh,
parts of the are really and walls of butting and in fact incorporating the,
uh,
the pyramid of Cassius.
But in antiquity,
it,
when it was first built,
excuse me,
it stood alone.
And what you see over here is a gateway that also belongs to the later a
religion walls.
So again,
fortunately the,
this particular tomb was preserved.
These two engravings are helpful in showing us that the inner core of the tomb
of Cassius was concrete and the outer pyramidal shape was faced once again with
travertine.
So travertine,
clearly the material of choice by aristocrats cause we're going to see the
Cassius was also an Aristocrat for their tombs in the age of Augustus,
concrete core,
travertine facing.
And then if you look at this cutaway view over here,
you will see that the burial chamber inside was very,
very,
very small,
very small.
So it's small enough that it's,
uh,
that was not a lot of space for these burials.
But we'll see that we still believe that this too was a family to
the burial chamber has had and still has remnants of a painted walls.
And I show you an engraving here of those walls that was made when they were in
somewhat better shape than they are today.
And I wondered if any of you,
you're such a experts now on first to forestall Roman wall painting.
If any of you could tell me,
I'm sure all of you could tell me what style painting,
uh,
is being used in the burial chamber of the Tomb of Cassius Kristin.
Third style.
Why third style
logical features
column,
very thin candelabra here and mythological figures.
How would the,
how would those use that make that show that this is a typical third style wall.
They have a black gun,
that's the word floating.
They are floating in this random space right in the center of the panels as we
know was characteristic of third style Roman wall painting.
So 15 BC,
third cell,
Roman wall painting.
And if you think back to some of the palace is that we looked at the palace is a
villas that we looked at and their dates.
Think of bus go Trey Causei for example,
11 BC.
You see this as roughly contemporary,
uh,
to what's happening in Campania at this particular time.
And here are two details,
uh,
of the remains of those paintings.
And you can see one of these floating mythological figures.
It looks like a victory figure,
female wing it carrying a wreath over here,
flying in the center of the panel.
This also shows you to,
in this case,
the panels were white,
a very similar to the walls,
for example,
of the third style.
And the Dome is our area in Rome.
And then here this candle labrum,
uh,
very attenuated,
very delicate,
uh,
that,
is used in place of columns decker at both of these motifs decorating the flat
wall.
Ah,
that was so characteristic of third style Roman wall painting.
Here's another view of the pyramid.
As it looks today,
you can see it is exceedingly well preserved,
one of the best preserved of all Roman tombs.
Uh,
it,
you can see again the way in which the later wall was built into it.
And you can also see the travertine blocks and how carefully carved they were by
the designers,
by the artisans.
And here,
this is very helpful because it shows you that the,
at least one,
but I can tell you the two sides of the tomb,
the eastern and western sides of the tomb had in the center of the pyramid,
the name of Cassius.
That's how we know it was his too.
You see it here.
Gaius Cassius.
And it also includes all of his title.
So he was very happy to advertise his titles on this monument,
which the purpose of which of course was for those who mourn,
Tim,
to feel proud of him and his achievements.
But even more important than that from his point of view,
I am sure I'm from the point of view of the Romans in general,
was that these,
that his name and his deeds be preserved for posterity.
So that some day in 2009,
we're sitting in this classroom,
uh,
looking at this,
we think back on Castias his title,
what he did,
what he achieved,
uh,
and uh,
the way in which he was memorialized.
So this whole idea of preserving memory,
uh,
not only in your own time,
but into the far flung future,
this tomb,
as I said,
despite the fact that the burial chamber is small,
we do believe it was a family tomb.
We have evidence for that because two bases were found or that seemed to belong
to this tune back as Cassius,
his name or members of his family Castillo.
So you can see there are named in these inscriptions.
Uh,
these have a markings on the top that suggest to us that statue stood on them at
one point.
So these were statue basis,
probably pray placed right in front of the entrance to the pyramidal tomb.
And if you cast your eyes over this inscription,
you will not only see the name Cassius a few times,
but you will see another very important name.
And that is m.
Dot.
AGRIPPA.
That's Marcus Agrippa.
That's the Marcus Agrippa,
uh,
the long time,
the boyhood friend and long time,
a close confidant and one time a air and son in law of Augustus.
Uh,
all of those things he's mentioned here.
So it is,
he is a member also of this family.
So it demonstrates to us,
again,
we are dealing with an aristocratic family.
So all of those tunes I've shown you thus far,
the mausoleum of Augustus,
the tomb of Cecilia Patella and the tomb of Gaius Cassius are all examples of
aristocratic to market texture in the age of Augustus.
Why did he choose to choose a pyramid for his tomb is a very interesting
question to ask and I would suggest here,
and it's not rocket science to figure this out at all.
I would suggest here though,
that the reason has to do with Augustus is very important.
Victory over Mark Antony and Cleopatra at the battle of Actium in 31.
Uh,
it was at that time and even before that,
an interest in things that Jim [inaudible],
uh,
came into Rome.
We saw that Augustus himself made reference to his victory over,
uh,
over,
um,
over the,
that pair over Cleopatra and Mark Antony in the complex with the,
our pacas and the mausoleum of Augustus by inserting that obelisk in the center.
And Obelisk that I've mentioned to you was actually brought from Egypt itself.
So these references to Egypt initially under Augustus himself had political
import.
It was there to show that Augustus had been,
that obelisk was there to show that Augustus had prevailed over Mark Antony and
Cleopatra.
And because he had prevailed,
he could,
he could steal obelisks from Egypt and bring them back to decorate Rome as
trophies essentially.
So that was a political statement on his part,
but as time went on,
a Egyptian Romania became a kind of fashion statement.
I think that it caught on.
It caught on after Egypt was made a Roman and 30 BC right after Actium.
And we begin to see this wave of things Egyptian,
uh,
spreading through Rome.
And it's likely that Castiel perhaps a combination of both since he's from a
grip as family,
uh,
this combination of political reference.
Uh,
but also just this was,
this was an interesting,
this was the style at this particular point,
uh,
to do things in the Egyptian manner.
You might remember some of those Egyptianize motifs that we saw,
for example,
from the black room at Bosco,
Trey Causei,
which was also a real,
a villa that was closely connected with the imperial family.
Remember grip a posthumous who was,
uh,
the son of a gripper himself,
born by Julie via his wife Julia.
After a grip is death,
hence his name.
Another view of the back of the Mosque of the pyramid of Castias,
the mausoleum of Cassius,
which again shows us how well preserved it is.
You can see the real you and walls.
You can see the gate that we looked at before.
And you can also see that the back is actually in a modern cemetery.
This is the so called Protestant cemetery.
And if you are in Rome and half time,
this is one of the most interesting places to visit.
It's again a bit off the beaten track that many tourists go there.
But those that do are rewarded because it's,
um,
it's a cemetery where many ex patriots,
uh,
were buried.
People who flocked to Rome because they loved it.
Authors,
a scholars,
poets,
painters,
came to Rome,
ended up spending the rest of their lives.
They're coming from all different countries around the world,
spending the rest of their lives.
They're dying there and eventually being buried in the so called Protestant
cemetery.
Uh,
Percy Vishy Shelly,
for example,
is buried there as is John Keats.
And the Keats tomb is my Keats marker,
is my favorite by far in the cemetery.
You can see his tombstone here,
uh,
which doesn't even give his name.
It just identifies them.
And you'll remember he died very,
very young and his 20,
early twenties,
I think it was a,
you see him here referred to only as the young English poet.
And down below it says here lies one whose name was rich in water.
It's an amazing,
uh,
stone.
It does show the liar,
which makes reference of course,
to the fluency and so on of his [inaudible] lift Louis poetry and overhear a
companion of his Joseph Severn,
who doesn't hesitate to mention his relationship to John Keats.
So you see Keats's name in Severns tunes,
don't,
uh,
but not in key to zone him.
So,
but I showed this to you just because it's one of those more fascinating,
uh,
places in Rome and many of the tombs,
by the way,
are there many tombstones here that clearly are based on ancient Roman a
prototype?
So it's a fascinating place to wander.
And by the way,
you can do that in our own Grove Street cemetery where there are a number of
tombs that are done very much in the Roman style.
If you think the Mazda,
the tomb of Cassius is unusual,
uh,
the weirdest tomb by far in Rome from ancient Rome is the one that I turned to
now.
And this is the tomb of the baker,
your Rissa keys,
the tomb of the baker,
your risk,
the keys that was put up in Rome in the late first century BC.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that again is another tumor in the age of August from the age of Augustus.
But in this case,
we believe,
although that the inscription doesn't,
it doesn't tell us this for sure,
uh,
but we believe it is highly likely that your recipes for is from a different
level of Roman society,
not an Aristocrat,
uh,
about a working man,
who may,
who probably either he himself or his realm or his family,
uh,
were slaves originally.
Eventually freed.
Uh,
he takes up the profession of bread making a and he ends up,
uh,
and,
and building this extraordinary tomb that I'm going to show you in some detail
in Rome.
As we look at this particular view,
we see the tomb of your recipes as it looks today.
It's right over here.
We see it is,
it is,
it has behind it a great travertine gate,
which is actually later in data dates to the time of the emperor Claudius.
We'll talk about it next week.
So you'll have to think that a way for the moment that was not standing,
uh,
when the tomb of your risky keys was put up.
A,
you can also see,
however,
that this gate was placed in a,
an aqueduct system that aqueduct was begun during the time of Augustus.
So you can imagine that at least some of that aqueduct system stood at the time
that this tomb was built.
The tomb,
as you can see here,
it was a three story structure,
very eccentric and its appearance.
You,
the bar,
the ground line today is much lower than the modern ground lines.
So you'd have to go right up to the monument.
You can look down at the first story.
So you're only seeing a part of the first story here.
Uh,
you can see that it is made of two full blocks.
You can also see the interior is concrete,
the core of the structure is concrete.
And then on the second and third stories,
uh,
it,
the tomb is faced with travertine.
So travertine,
again,
a use for tune facing in the age of Augustus.
Uh,
and we see this very unusual design where there are these great,
these great,
uh,
you know,
I couldn't,
not peers,
um,
uh,
cylinders,
great cylinders,
great cylinders that are placed here vertically,
and then cylinders placed in the next tier,
horizontally,
vertically placed in cylinders.
They're not columns.
You don't see any capitals.
They're very fat.
Uh,
so they are cylinders,
uh,
vertically and then horizontally.
And some scholars have suggested,
and I think quite convincingly,
that these may actually make reference to what we're grain measure.
Grain measures were these cylindrical structures in silos in a sense in which
they stored grain in ancient Roman times.
Uh,
so that is very possible since we know that this man was a baker,
uh,
that this may make reference to these grain storage cylinders,
that were used in the process of baking
with regard to the siting of the tomb.
This is particularly interesting.
Uh,
I show you,
uh,
this plan over here,
which indicates to us here you can actually see the plan of the tomb of your
recipes,
and you can see that it is very unusual in shape.
It is trap a Zodol in shape.
Why is it trap as oil and shape?
Uh,
it probably is dropped the soil in shape because the tomb was located on a piece
of property that was between two major roads of this,
of the,
of Rome,
uh,
that exited and entered the city at this particular point,
the so called via lobby Connor and the via Prajna Stena.
So two major Roman roads,
uh,
that come into the city at this point.
And remember the tomb of your recipes,
like all Roman tombs,
uh,
during this period where it was outside the Serbian walls.
So build outside the walls,
but between these two,
two,
uh,
two streets,
now this model over here,
which by the way comes from a museum in Rome that again is off the beaten track,
but I can highly recommend the Museo achievable Tar Romana,
uh,
which is in a building built by muscle Leni in the 1930s for a world's fair.
And the buildings and it,
it and other buildings like it out there in a place part of Rome that we call a
ar from expos,
Espositos Yonei universe,
Salai the Roma a you are a or a that whole area built up by Mussolini for the
world's fair.
But the buildings were so substantial that they decided to keep them and they
still stand.
And this museum was placed in,
um,
in,
in one of them.
It is a museum of casts where you can go and see works of Roman art and
architecture from not only Rome but from around the world all in one place.
Now they're not originals,
they're cast,
but it's a great big,
great place to study for the exam,
for this course,
for example,
because you could walk around and see so many of the buildings that we've talked
about and there are these wonderful models of many of them.
And we see here a model of this aqueduct,
the later,
a little later gate here and the tomb of your recipes.
And this shows you very well the way in which these two streets,
the lobby ICANA and the prime minister came into Rome at this point converge
exactly on the facade of this too.
Uh,
and this,
this is clearly,
I mean,
it is clear that your recipes,
and I'll tell you how he did this in a moment,
had enough money that he was able to buy what was certainly one of the most
choice pieces of real estate outside the walls of Rome.
Uh,
one in which everyone who came into Rome from either of those two thoroughfares
would see the facade of this to.
And this is a man who wanted to be remembered for posterity.
It's another example of how tombs were used for the purposes retaining memory
over time.
This is also interesting because it shows what happened,
what you see with the dotted lines.
Here is one of these later gates that was made for the [inaudible] walls.
Uh,
and in this case,
the tomb of your recipes was right smack dab in the middle of where they wanted
to build a outcropping of this wall.
In this case,
they decided that they were not going to build the wall into it,
but that they were going to build the wall on top of it.
But fortunately,
again,
they did not destroy,
they did not destroy it completely.
They did shear off the front of the tomb,
which actually took away the facade,
but they allowed the debris to fall into the tower,
uh,
s and then they covered it up.
So when,
when,
so when this tower was eventually torn down to free the tomb of your Rissa keys,
they found the fourth wall and the debris from that wall,
including a portrait statute and description inside,
uh,
the debris,
which was extremely fortunate and which allows us to reconstruct the monument.
Here you see the,
uh,
the model,
the model in the,
uh,
in this AOR museum that shows you what the two of them looked like in antiquity.
You see the three levels,
the three tiers,
you see the entrance to the burial chamber here.
Uh,
and this is the facade that we're looking at.
This is the part that no longer survives.
This is the fourth wall or the facade.
Now gone.
Uh,
but we can again reconstructed from those remains and you see them here and you
see it was relatively plain on three tiers except for a portrait statue of your
recipes and his wife an inscription down below.
And you need to think a way the frees up there,
because the freeze was probably not on this side of the monument,
although there was a freeze around the other three sides.
You can see one of those sides here and I'll show that freeze to you
momentarily.
This is a view of the tomb again,
where we can see so well those cylinders on two stories.
Uh,
and you can also see here that in the uh,
area between the vertical and the horizontal cylinders,
on three sides of the monument,
there is an inscription and it repeats over and over again.
And it tells us that this monument was put up by your Rissa keys.
Marcus Virgo alias Uris,
the keys,
uh,
who was peace store and redemptive for pis,
t o r r e d e m p t o r p store and redemptor.
That means master Baker and contractor.
The contractor is a very,
the most important part,
master Baker and contractor.
We know this is a man who made bread and sold it to the Roman armies.
This was a pretty lucrative thing to do in the age of Augustus when there was so
much military conquest,
he made a fortune selling bread to the Roman armies.
And it is with that fortune that he was able to buy this choice piece of real
estate and to put up this extraordinary monument in the late first century BC,
the portrait reliefs still survives.
It's in the Capitol and museums today.
You see it here.
It had fallen in again to the debris from the fourth side,
but here it is with your Rissa keys,
a standing next to his wife [inaudible].
We know her name and I'll tell you how in a moment,
artists in that portrait relief,
and we're not going to go into this in any detail,
but if you compare it to the figures of Augustus and his family from the our
pockets,
I think you'll agree with me that the are a pockets is serving as a model.
Uh,
and that this portrait group is clearly based on a risk Socratic,
even though this is probably a middleclass,
a pair,
a formally from a slave family freed people,
uh,
they are,
shown here very much as if they are members of the court wearing similar,
uh,
costumes depicted in a similar way with similar hairstyles.
And I point to just one detail.
If you look at this view of Livia on the RF pacas Augustus,
his wife,
and you see the wonderful way in which the artist has depicted her hand,
the shape of her hand showing underneath her garment here.
The same is done here for a [inaudible].
You can see,
and that's at t I s t I a [inaudible].
You can see her hand.
In fact,
it's even better done here because you can see the shape of the knuckles and so
on.
Underneath the garment,
the,
um,
very diaphanous garment that she wears.
So clearly a very special portrait artists probably hired to do these portraits,
a portrait artists,
uh,
who,
um,
may have been hired at,
at great expense and also very significant.
And in keeping with what we saw for the tomb of Cecilia Metalla is the fact that
although the tomb is faced in travertine and the relief around the monument is
in Travertine,
this is done in marble,
uh,
in,
in if I remember correctly,
Greek marble,
uh,
as well.
So important marble,
uh,
that is brought from elsewhere,
and at greater expense,
uh,
is used for the most important portrait relief.
The scenes around the free the scenes,
the freeze scenes are particularly interesting because they depict in the
greatest of detail,
uh,
the,
the profession of the making of bread.
They depict,
uh,
your risk,
the keys d daily achievement,
uh,
of making bread that he sold to the Roman armies.
I'm going to just show you the scenes very quickly and you can see the style is
very different.
It's a much more journalistic style,
uh,
with figures with that,
with figures that don't have the elegant proportions that we saw on the portrait
relief.
And it is carved on travertine,
not on marble.
We see here the grain being ground between two stones.
Uh,
and we see the way in which these,
those,
these,
these men and tunics,
uh,
work that we also see that the upper stone is rotated by a mule that is attached
to a wooden handle that comes off the upper a stone there.
We have mill stones just like this from Pohnpei and I show you the actual
millstones.
So these depictions on the tomb of your risk,
he's very accurate.
Uh,
in terms of what millstones looked like in antiquity.
A number,
another scene here in which we see two men at a table with big gobs of dough
that you can see here,
doe,
uh,
for the bread.
Another scene,
this is one of the more important scenes where we see four men standing behind a
table that are forming that dough into loaves a and overhear a magistrate,
a who has a low,
a short sleeved,
but long garment is supervising them.
And the four men are very interestingly rendered because they're rendered almost
exactly the same.
If you look,
if you compare this to the Arra pockets where figures are represented in
different postures,
a lot of variety,
clearly based on Greek prototypes.
Here we see something very different.
The major objective of the artist is to get the story across to show these men
making these,
uh,
this,
these loaves.
But look at them.
Each one,
they're bare chested and we'll see why they're bare chest.
It's hot in this part of the,
uh,
of the bakery.
So they've taken off their shirts.
There's some attempted to pick their musculature,
but they're essentially shown in exactly the same way,
the same curly hair,
uh,
as almost as if they were cut from a cookie cutter.
Because again,
it's not the form that's of interest to the artists here,
but getting that narrative across and,
and if you try to figure out whose legs belong to who,
believe me,
you'll have a difficult time of it.
So the artist is not as much less a concern with formal things than he is with
getting the story across with regard to why they've taken off their shirts.
They're right near the oven.
Uh,
and I show you this scene that depicts the dome shaped oven,
uh,
in which the loaves are being baked a and you can see that this oven looks very
much like a modern pizza oven and in fact the pole that they use the wooden pole
with the flat,
uh,
and uh,
is just the sort of thing you see at bar or anywhere,
any other major pizza place either in new haven or elsewhere in the world.
And in fact,
these dome shaped ovens are still,
you oozed in rural areas in I took this view and uh,
in Greece,
uh,
in a small rural town and,
you see these in Italy and some very small towns as well,
still being,
you done in exactly the same way.
There are a number because of the cylinders on the tomb of your recipes.
There are some scholars have suggested that the tomb of [inaudible] keys is in
the form of a bakery.
While I do believe that there is reference to those grain,
to those storage bins,
silos that were used for the storage of grain.
I do not think that the tomb of [inaudible] is in the form of an oven.
It makes reference to baking,
but I don't think it's in the form of an oven because this is what Roman ovens
looked like.
They were dome shaped.
Uh,
this has a very different appearance.
As you can see.
Perhaps the most important scene in the freeze is this one.
Uh,
where we see a tool,
we see the lobes have been baked,
they're ready to go to market,
uh,
and they're put in these large baskets.
You can see them your,
and then they are weighed in this scale,
this ancient scale.
And I think this is a form of private propaganda on the part of the baker.
You Rissa keys.
What he is telling the public who gaze up on this tomb,
not only in his own day but for posterity is my bread was always not only of
high quality but of the appropriate weight.
I never cheated the public.
I treated you fairly.
I was an honest baker and contractor.
I think that's what the message is here.
And in fact,
uh,
you may think this is a stretch,
but I think that one could easily compare.
Uh,
this report that you receive the keys provides of his profession on the freeze
of this tomb as a kind of Baker's version of Augustus is raised guests die.
The list of things accomplished during his life is laid out in narrative form
for not only his contemporaries,
but for posterity.
To see the portrait group again,
and I mentioned that there was an inscription found with that portrait group,
a very interesting inscription,
which tells us that you Rissa keys put up this monument to his wife.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
is bodily remains,
he says are buried in Hoke Panare Mayo in Hoke preneurial in this [inaudible],
what is a panare IOM,
a bread basket,
which is again why scholars have said,
well,
the whole tomb is in the form of an oven,
but I think the breadbasket being referred to here is not the tomb,
but rather the urn in which artists he,
his remains were placed in the excavation in the 19th century.
When that later,
uh,
gateway was removed,
they found one earn one earn,
not two earns,
one earn,
uh,
presumably the urn of [inaudible],
and that earn,
uh,
was in the form.
It was drawn at that time.
And we can see this view of it here.
I Cross section the lid and the main body of the earn.
And you can see it looks like a bread basket.
Uh,
and I show you,
we have lots of examples of urns in the form of bread baskets and Roman tons is
one in the Metropolitan Museum of art.
You,
if any of you who are going down there anytime soon to look at Roman antiquities
and other things,
you can see one there.
This one is in the national museum in Rome.
Uh,
and women's remains were often placed in bread baskets to accentuate or to speak
to their,
uh,
their domestic virtues that they were good at taking care of the house and
baking bread and so on.
Uh,
but in this particular case,
I think it is much more likely that the reference here is not to her,
her two autistic.
He is,
uh,
cleverness as a housekeeper,
but rather to her husband's profession,
which very,
very interesting in terms of what it tells us about the,
the gender wars of,
of antiquity,
that here's a tune that has been put up by this baker with his money that he's
made from his profession in honor of his wife.
But what he depicts,
what he,
what he is preserving for posterity is not the outline of his wife's life,
but the outline of his life,
what he has accomplished.
His name is plastered on three sides of the monument.
Uh,
he's got three sides of the monument with the EV,
the successive phases of the baking of bread in all of its aspects.
Yes,
he has a very nice portrait relief of his wife,
but of course he's standing by her side.
I need,
does mention her name down below.
So I'm,
he gives her some do.
But this monument as far as posterity is concerned,
is about,
uh,
your risk,
the keys and not about his wife.
And I think it tells us,
again,
vary a great deal about the motives of this particular individual.
I want to say just a very few words about two other tombs out on the via Apia in
Rome,
the RP and way again,
and I show you a view of the Bia Apia as it looks today.
Uh,
you can see that although much of the road is modern,
you do find a bits and pieces of ancient ground out there.
You can see some polygonal blocks here and some red marks,
uh,
from the ancient road.
And you have to be very careful when you drive out there and your chink with
Jane Doe or whatever,
uh,
two or you bike ride out there as this fellow is doing where you take your
motorbike or whatever,
uh,
because if you're going too quickly and you don't really,
you know,
you don't expect that all of a sudden you hit some ancient road and that makes a
huge difference in terms of your ability to get to move forward.
I want to show you one tune very fleetingly out there,
uh,
which is the one that you see over here on the left hand side of the screen.
There remains of many tombs on the via Apia.
Most of them are just piles of concrete,
but a few of them are better preserved.
And this is one of them.
It's a tomb of a Friedman and Friedman and freed women from 13 BC to five.
Uh,
we call it the rebury his tomb because of an inscription on it tells us members
of the [inaudible] family were buried here.
The reason that I show it to you is that the eccentric tombs that I've shown you
today are absolutely marvelous and tell us a lot about the Romans as patrons and
as and their desires,
visa,
the memory.
Uh,
but it is not,
those are not the conventional tomb types.
We see many more of this sort of thing,
which we call a house tomb,
a tomb that resembles a house.
Essentially it has a sloping a ceiling and you know,
a main facade.
Uh,
and in that facade there is usually a portrait relief,
either vertical or horizontal.
Uh,
but these horizontal ones represent members of the family.
Some may be deceased,
some may not be deceased.
The messages that,
uh,
even if someone has died before another,
that they will eventually be reunited together in perpetuity.
But if you look at this carefully,
you will see that what it looks like is as if these individuals are still alive
and looking out of the window of their tomb,
as,
as if out of the window of a house is very close association in the mind of the
Romans between houses of the living and houses.
Of the dead,
uh,
and,
that,
that is absolutely the case here.
And you'll remember,
we can trace this all the way back to the eighth century BC.
You remember the hut,
the a Villanovan hut earn that I showed you,
and I told you that women's remains were placed in women's cremated remains,
were placed in these huts that resembled Romulus is huts.
Uh,
and uh,
and so this whole idea of a house serving as a tomb goes way back,
uh,
and continues to be a light motif of a Roman two markitecture,
throughout the entire history of Roman architecture.
And it's something that I hope you'll keep in mind.
Also,
just in passing,
I want to mention we've looked,
the tombs that we've looked at thus far today have been primary.
They'd been of all different social classes from emperor to freed slave,
uh,
but at the same time,
they have all been tombs,
including the raspberries tomb of the well to do a,
if these were freed slaves,
they were ones that made a fortune,
like your receipt keys did,
selling bread to the Roman army.
Uh,
and with that fortune we're able to build monumental tombs at great expense.
But there were lots and lots of people obviously who lived in Rome and palm pay
and in other cities who could not afford a,
those kinds of tunes.
And you might be asking yourself,
where were all of those people buried?
Well,
they tended to be buried underground,
uh,
in what we call Columbaria,
c o,
l,
U M,
B a r I a Columbaria,
uh,
underground burial chambers,
that were either a burial,
uh,
clubs that you could join for a small amount of money.
You could join one of these clubs,
uh,
buy in to your last resting place that way.
Or they were burial chambers that were created by the very well to do,
for example,
the Emperor Emperor Augustus in Libya.
We know they had thousands of slaves,
literally thousands of slaves.
We have a record of some of Olivia's slave.
She had slaves not only to tend the garden and that kind of thing,
but she had a massage.
She had several hairstylist and she even had a slave.
We know who set her pearls.
That was her whole job was to set her pearls day in and day out.
So they had tons and tons of slaves and some of those very well to do,
uh,
also established these burial areas where their slaves could find a last resting
place.
And in fact,
the one that I show you here,
the Vignette Codine,
uh,
is one such that belonged to the Julio to Augusta and Julio,
Claudia and family,
uh,
and was used for the remains of some of their slaves.
And you can see that each individual had a little niche and people were
cremated.
The cremated remains,
I were placed usually in an urn,
uh,
that was placed inside one of these niches.
And then there would be a small inscription referring to the deceased.
So this gives you a sense again,
of those who could not afford individual tombs and how they were buried in the,
in the fiber or seven minutes that remain.
Uh,
I'd like to switch gears entirely and look at something very different as a
prelude to what we'll be talking about next time.
Because next time,
next Tuesday,
we are going to return once again to innovative Roman architecture,
architecture,
uh,
made,
concrete,
uh,
and with a variety of interesting innovations.
We'll do that next week as I said,
and I wanted to give you an introduction to that by turning to this one example
from the Augustan period that is note worthy enough for us to say something
about it.
This is what you're looking at here is the plan of what was,
uh,
a spa,
essentially an ancient Roman times.
It's located in Campania at a place called bias.
So in the vicinity of Pompeii and Herculaneum and [inaudible] and Bosco,
Trey Cozzie and so on.
We've already talked about the fact that that was an area that was a mecca for
the well to do the glitterati from Rome who went down there for their vacations.
It was a resort area.
Many of them had villas along what is now the Amalfi coast.
Uh,
others had villas on the island of coppery at,
can't remember if I told you,
but Augustus and Tiberius,
his successor owned 12 villas on the island of coppery,
one of which we'll look at next time.
Uh,
and uh,
this was an area also where there were sulphur springs and mineral baths.
And so the natural thing to do for those who are coming here as a resort was to
create for them a place that they could go to relax and enjoy the thermal
springs and the sulfur baths and so on and so forth.
And that was this place,
this spa,
uh,
at bio,
which consisted of a bunch of thermal structures that were terrorist out over a
hillside.
You have to think of the sanctuary or Fortuna Prima Jania at Palestrina a turned
into a spa because they treated it architecturally,
it was done in exactly the same way.
They took a hillside,
they terrorist that hillside,
they poured concrete on that hillside,
creating a whole host of interesting structures in which one could relax and get
away from it all.
Uh,
you see a plan of that spot here in the way in which it was terrorist via
concrete construction over this hillside.
I am only going to show you one thermal bath,
uh,
from it.
And it's this one that we see over here.
It is the so called Temple of Mercury.
That's what the locals have long called.
And it is not a temple of Mercury.
It is a thermal bath.
Uh,
but nonetheless we call it that because it's been called that for such a long
time.
As you look at the plan of the temple of Mercury,
you're going to say to me,
every one of you will say the same thing.
What's the origin of this?
Clearly the design is based on the frigging Daria of Pompei,
the Frigidaire him or the cold room of Pompei.
This round structure with the radiating alcoves that we saw as part of bath
architecture very early on,
second century BC and so on in palm pay,
same scheme.
He was here.
Not Surprising.
This is in Campania.
It's not far away.
Uh,
I can show you the temple of Mercury is extremely well preserved.
We can see the dome of the Temple of Mercury made out of concrete construction
from above.
You can see the Oculus of the,
just as those for free.
Daria had ocularly,
ocular [inaudible],
uh,
this one does as well.
And you can see that extremely well here.
So a concrete building with a concrete dome,
uh,
used as part of the spa.
We've traced this desire to make round structures way back,
uh,
to the six hundreds BC.
The time of Quinto Fiorentino I showed you this,
a trust can attempt at making a round structure with a dome,
uh,
that,
was done in this case in stone.
And although it was a valiant attempt,
not all that successful,
uh,
and we talked about the way in which that eventually transformed into the Roman,
ability to make the freaky Daria at palm pay.
And here are two views of the temple of Mercury at via as it looks today.
Uh,
because of the Oculus,
uh,
there's often rainwater,
the drain,
no longer functions.
Uh,
so there's often a lot of very,
um,
uh,
on appealing green,
water that,
that accumulates in the base of the temple of Mercury.
So The Times that I've been there,
every time I think I've been there,
there's been enough water in there that I haven't been able to actually get
pictures of the alcoves,
which are covered by these inches and inches of water that are usually collected
inside the temple of Mercury.
But you get a good sense,
I think of it here nonetheless,
that we're talking about around dome structure with an Oculus,
with some windows,
with a RQ weighted windows,
windows with our occupations at the top in the upper most part are toward the
upper most part of the dome to add additional light into the system.
And,
uh,
you need to think of these,
by the way,
as much more ornate and antiquity than they are today.
They would have been,
uh,
stuccoed over,
which you can see and then probably decorated with mosaic.
So the wonderful effects of the light coming in,
hitting the mosaic.
Uh,
and then there would have been a pool in the center just as there wasn't the
frigate Darian around people,
which people could sit,
uh,
you would,
it would have been a quite spectacular space and I just,
just a few more views to end with today.
Uh,
this one up here,
which of course is the frigging Darian at palm pay to show you where all of this
begins.
These two views are of the temple of Mercury at Baia and this one of course of
the Pantheon,
which is where we're headed,
but I think these in particular of the temple of Mercury at Baia,
again,
give you a sense of the way in which light not only flows into the system.
Again,
imagine on mosaic sealing and mosaic walls,
spectacular effects the glue,
the way it would have glittered in the light.
But look,
especially at the way the,
the shape of the shapes that are formed on the water,
that would have been in the pool down below.
Uh,
it's exactly the same,
the same sort of sense that you get when you walk into the Pantheon today,
which also makes circles on the floor of the pavement.
So we're going to again,
return to these kinds of issues next week.
I just wanted you to be aware of this intermediate step between the frigate
Daria upon pay and some of the buildings that we're going to be looking at in
the next couple of weeks.
Hey,
care,
thank you.
And Happy Valentine's Day.
Everyone.